nominees for the best original song are
from the Karate Kid Part two glory of
love performed by Peter Cetera music by
Peter Cetera and David Foster near five
Peter Cetera and Diane meaning from
that's life life another pink glass
performed by Tony Bennett music by Henry
Mancini's art by Leslie Brutus Mean
Green mother from outer space performed
by levi stubbs music by Alan Menken
limit by Howard Ashman
from an American tale somewhere out
there performed by Natalie Cole and
James Ingram music by James Horner and
Barry Mann yard by Cynthia Weil from Top
Gun take my breath away performed by
Melba Moore and Lou Rawls music by
Giorgio Moroder merit by Tom Whitlock
where is uh when I got you
what a surprise I didn't I didn't think
there were so many great songs this year
and this I really like I would like to
thank the director Tony Scott
the producers Jerry Bruckheimer Don
Simpson and Tom would like to think like
to thank everyone at Paramount the
artist Terri Nunn in Berlin
my friend Giorgio Moroder and have to go
there thank you all thank you very much